alors si on jorian beaux jours bonjour
c'est d'être là vous avez regardé avec
attention ce baromètre longuement il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire et on va en
parler est d'abord on va parler des
préoccupations alors ça confirme un peu
ce qu'on s'est dit au long de la
campagne sur les préoccupations des
français le pouvoir d'achat principale
préoccupation des français c'est ce qui
ressort un nom de cette grande étude
réalisée entre les 15 et 18 avril sur un
très large échantillon représentatif de
la population vous le disais royal alors
le pouvoir d'achat revient régulièrement
et très loin devant le système de santé
ou encore la guerre en ukraine ou encore
l'environnement qui sont à égalité on
notera aussi et bien que le chômage qui
revenait un peu traditionnellement au
centre des préoccupations des français
lors des échéances précédentes et bien
et bon dernier de ce classement il ne
sommes il ne semble plus du tout
préoccupé les français qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
sur la question du chômage c'est assez
c'est assez simple il ya deux raisons la
première c'est que en général un enjeu
une préoccupation va dominer une
hiérarchie de deux thèmes de politique
publique
lorsque aucune autre thématique ne vient
s'imposer ou s'écraser et pendant cette
campagne effectivement au delà du
chômage qui était présent dans près de
quarante ans de vie politique française
gros plan national la grande nouveauté
s'est écrasé parce que premièrement il a
une amélioration macroéconomique avec
toujours ce dilemme entre la réalité des
chiffres agrégé et la perception
individuelle mais on voit quand même une
évolution sur ce terrain là en
particulier sur des segments qui par le
passé
étaient sources d'attention chômage des
très jeunes moins de 24 ans et puis le
taux d'activité des plus de 55 ans donc
là il ya eu une amélioration mais c'est
surtout que derrière cette amélioration
cela a produit de profondes inégalités
entre des personnes occupant un travail
et pour autant c'est tout le tout le
mouvement des gilet jaune n'étant pas en
capacité de pouvoir répondre à quitter
un certain nombre de dépenses
contraintes donc le pouvoir d'achat
a pris la place sur cette question
économique et social individuel la place
du chômage oui c'est intéressant de
regarder de commencer non pas en
regardant ce que sont les premières
priorités mais ce que sont les dernières
priorités et c'est vrai que le fait que
le chômage soit en queue de liste c'est
une nouveauté c'est pas la première fois
qu'ils soient aussi bas c'est la
première fois mais que ce ne soit pas la
première priorité ce n'est pas la
première fois on se souvient qu'en 2002
peu à peu la question du chômage et du
pouvoir d achat avait laissé place à la
question de la sécurité qui était devenu
le thème le thème dominant on voit aussi
que la question des déficits publics qui
avaient occupé qui était une des
premières priorités dans les deux
précédentes campagnes là quoi qu'il en
coûte oblige
seulement 14% seulement 14 % donc loin
très loin des autres priorités et puis
comme souvent lorsque la priorité pour
le chômage baisse eh bien c'est la
priorité pour le pouvoir d'achat qui par
un jeu de vases communicants peu à peu
s'imposer là c'est quoi cette fois ci
quand on regarde la tête de lice ce qui
est frappant non seulement quand on
regarde la vague d'aujourd'hui mais
quand on regarde l'évolution puisque
cette enquête on l'a commencée en avril
2021 quand on regarde l'évolution
notamment depuis le début de cette année
on voit que vague après vague la
question du pouvoir d'achat peu à peu
est devenue la priorité écrasante et que
l'écart entre le pouvoir d'achat et
toutes les autres priorités n'a été que
sa croissance on a eu toute une
précampagne qui a été dominée par la
question de l'immigration 1 entre entre
le mois de septembre et le mois de
décembre désormais l'écart entre
l'immigration et le pouvoir d'achat est
de 32 points est ce que ça veut dire que
sur ce terrain du pouvoir d'achat ces
avantages à marine le pen qui est parti
très tôt en campagne là dessus alors que
le bilan des manuels mâcon sur le sujet
n'est pas compris des français comme
étant un beau but les français disent
mais nous on a l'impression pas le
pouvoir d'achat a baissé
moi je suis je suis surpris de
l'observation qui est souvent fait en
dix ans marine le pen s'est approprié
l'enjeu du pouvoir d'achat en réalité
marine le pen n'a pas démarré sa
campagne sur les questions de pouvoir
d'achat essentiellement sur la question
des libertés et beaucoup d'affichés
d'ailleurs ont été ôtés présente dans
l'espace public sur les libertés et je
crois qu'elle est là elle a réussi non
seulement à faire le constat que cette
thématique ne fertilité pas dans
l'opinion et donc on a eu à la rentrée
de septembre toute cette question sur la
hausse des prix de l'énergie le gaz
électricité et donc celle là à mener
finalement à être la première à se
saisir d'un enjeu qui apparaissait dans
différentes enquêtes et ça se trouve
c'est très intéressant parce que pour la
première fois on a une préoccupation sur
laquelle aucun des candidats n'avait
préparé démarré leur campagne
présidentielle sur cet enjeu et c'est le
thème c'est cette préoccupation qui
s'est imposée aux candidats et certains
ont mieux réagi plus rapidement et avec
des propositions j'allais dire plus plus
tangible plus perceptible pour
l'électorat obligeant les autres
candidats à devoir souvent rattrapé un
retard sur cette question donc à la
mieux jouer politiquement
ce que vous dites est juste s'agissant
de d'emmanuel la cour la difficulté dans
laquelle il s est qu'il ya un écart
entre les chiffres des statistiques
publiques sur le bilan de ce quinquennat
et le discours qui a été tenu pendant
des mois en par la majorité
présidentielle c'est le quinquennat dans
lequel le pouvoir d'achat en moyenne a
le plus augmenté notamment par rapport
aux deux quinquennats précédent et que
cette augmentation s'est fait sur
l'ensemble de la distribution des
revenus même si elle a été un peu près
était plus forte sur les 10 % ou les 5%
de plus riches donc cet écart entre les
statistiques publiques d'un côté et la
perception d'un autre côté puisque pour
le coup vous avez à peine 10 % des
français qui disent mon pouvoir d'achat
a augmenté dans la période perception
qui s'explique sans doute par le fait
qu' on a eu une poussée de l'inflation
une augmentation du prix d'un certain
nombre de matières premières ou de
produits alimentaires dans les dernières
semaines et que ceux qui comptent mais
c'est plus les dernières semaines que
les derniers mois ou que les dernières
années donc emmanuel macron à ces
difficultés à gérer il l'aura d'ailleurs
pendant le pendant le débat ce qui est
intéressant quand on regarde les
chiffres de l' enquête c'est que la
crédibilité comparée des manuels macro
et de marine le pen alors que marine le
pen a fait toute sa campagne sur ce
sujet là elle a une avance mais qui est
une avance relativement légères 45%
selon emmanuel macron 53% pour marine le
pen évidemment parler
mais d'abord c'est autre chose
oui les intentions de vote emmanuel
macron qui creuse en quelque sorte les
cas il prend deux points par rapport à
la précédente vague il ya 56 %
d'intentions de vote au second tour
contre 44% pour marine le pen en ce qui
concerne le report de voix ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'électorat mélenchon
cet électorat votera à 36% pour emmanuel
macron à 19% pour marine le pen selon
cette même étude 45% de l'électorat
mélenchon n'a pas souhaité exprimé
d'intention de vote pour le second tour
et puis quand on demande aux français
ainsi le choix maquereau ou le pen est
un choix par adhésion ou un choix par
défaut 55 % de l'électorat macron répond
que c'est un choix par adhésion contre
45 % d'électeurs qui disent qu'ils
voteront marc roux macron par défaut
chez marine le pen ils sont 58% à voter
par adhésion pour la candidate 42% le
feront en revanche faute de mieux au
premier tour on choisit au deuxième tour
on élimine c'est ça se confirme encore
selon vous
définitivement et je crois par rapport
aux sujets qu'on ait évoqué tout à
l'heure sur les thématiques c'est
décisif parce que si les candidats n'ont
peu de différences entre eux ça va être
compliqué compliqué de pour les
électeurs français d'éliminer parce
qu'ils ne verront pas vrai la différence
entre les deux candidats sur des sur des
questions majeures pour les
préoccupations des français donc cette
campagne d'entre deux tours au regard
des chiffres que vous venez d'indiquer
est très intéressant parce que on aurait
pu penser qu'il y avait pire eu un
mouvement massif de votes par défaut la
fameuse contre-démocratie de pierre
rosanvallon l'historien c'est plus
nuancé oui bien sûr qu'il ya des
réserves de voix qui manquent
aujourd'hui aux deux candidats pour
l'emporter et qui sont mobilisés motivé
avant tout par par défaut on a eu notre
un autre élément dans l' enquête qui est
très intéressant c'est le nombre de
personnes qui indiquent aujourd'hui
vouloir voter pour faire barrage c'est
cette idée du vote négatif ça sert vote
par des fois aussi c'est une partie du
vote par défaut mais on peut faire
barrage faire barrage ça veut dire que
vraiment on contribue à éliminer
éliminer quelqu'un est donc
effectivement c'est la fameuse maxime du
du ciu scrutin à deux tours lors du
deuxième tour il faut éliminer donc ce
n'est pas un choix d'adhésion on ne
retrouve le choix d'adhésion que pour
les électorats historique des manuels
macron et jean luc mélenchon de toutes
les difficultés c'est à la fois essayer
de ne pas s'aliéner une partie de
l'électorat qui manqueraient pour
constituer une majorité mais dans le
même temps ne pas s'aliéner une partie
de l'électorat veut dire qu'on doit
choisir des thématiques bien précises
ont fait la différence par rapport à son
adversaire
le choix de barrage est-ce que vous
votez pour barrer la route à l'autre
candidat c'est 39% chez emmanuel macron
38% chez marine le pen c'est très élevé
on est dans un vote de rejet plus tôt
dans un vote d'adhésion bien sûr on est
d'abord dans un format d'abord dans un
second tour juge au point la formule au
premier tour on choisit au deuxième tour
en élimine c'est pas vrai je crois que
c'est assez vrai sur le deuxième tome
est que ce n'est plus si vrai qu cent
pour le premier on a vu comme jamais une
dynamique de vote utile
s'opérer et s'opérer en s'accélérant au
fur et à mesure que l'on s'approchait du
vote ou
le candidat qui était en tête sur chaque
espace politique à aspirer tout ce qu'il
y avait dans cet espace politique et
c'est comme ça que marine le pen fini à
24 ou près de 24 et que jean luc
mélenchon fini à 1 après 2,22 donc dès
le premier tour on commence à on
commence à éliminer deuxièmement ce que
vous indiquez sur le report des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon il faut
le regarder aussi chez l'elysée dans les
autres électorat et je crois qu'il
faudra regarder c'est le nombre de
suffrages exprimés
c'est à dire de regarder à la fois quel
va être le taux d'abstention et quel va
être le nombre de bulletins blancs parce
que on voit que il y en avait eu
beaucoup il ya vu un record historique
en 2017 on avait eu 9 % de bulletins
blancs au deuxième tour est ce que ce
chiffre là va être à nouveau battu en
2000 en 2022 donc ça je crois que c'est
la deuxième chose qui va falloir
regarder et puis sur le niveau des
intentions de vote 54 46 on voit que par
rapport aux premières enquêtes qui ont
été réalisées non pas par ce panel mais
par les nombreuses enquêtes qui ont été
publiés depuis le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle l'écart
augmente il augmente de manière qui
n'est pas considérable mais il augmente
alors comment on espère que ça c'est la
bonne compagnie l macron c'est le fait
qu'il met en lumière le programme de
marine le pen on sait le sait les
barrages contre l'extrême mais je crois
que on dit souvent c'est une nouvelle
campagne qui commence et pour partie
c'est vrai sert qu'on a une offre qui
est simplifié il n'y a plus que deux
candidats on a un
un débat qui est beaucoup plus de
tangible cirque on a beaucoup beaucoup
plus parlé des propositions des
propositions des deux candidats durant
ces quelques jours que durant les tous
les mois précédents de campagne on a un
débat qui empreint d'une gravité plus
importante parce qu'on sait que l'un des
deux sera président de la république le
24 avril prochain et je crois que cette
cette inversion ou 29 7 heures et vous
gardez des intentions de vote il
s'explique pour partie par les campagnes
je crois que manuela prophéte meilleure
campagne de second tour que deux
premiers notamment il y met davantage
d'intensité je crois qu'ils s'expliquent
aussi par la mobilisation de la société
civile qui a été beaucoup plus
importante que dans l'élection
présidentielle de 2010 est sans doute
parce que les écarts sont malgré tout ça
c'est
de syndicalistes
je pense que ça a contribué parce que
pour un électeur de jean luc mélenchon
au fond ce que dit emmanuel macron est
important mais il ya assez peu de
chances qu'un électeur de jean luc
mélenchon de vienne afin fervents
supporters des manuels maquereau en
l'espace de 15 jours et que donc le
moteur principal de 100 votes malgré
tout c'est l'opposition à marine le pen
et la réactivation de ce qu'est le
programme de marine le pen je crois
était un élément important dans ces
évolutions oui non non je partage c'est
vrai que c'est quand même la deuxième
élection consécutive où les électeurs
vont devoir davantage se prononcer et
exprimer un vote de rejet plutôt qu'un
mode de projet est donc cette situation
nous dit quelque chose qui fonctionne
pas très bien dans dans le pays et il
est la vie démocratique de la france
alors oui on peut dire il y a il est
aujourd'hui bien sûr cette élection est
importante et on espère que le taux de
participation sera le plus élevé mais
quand vous indiqué tout à l'heure le
report de vote c'est vrai que c'est le
point crucial de cette élection parce
que les deux candidats on voit bien que
les réserves de voix sont sont
extrêmement faibles sur plusieurs blocs
donc il ya un bloc important le blog de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon
j'observe quand même que dans les
reports de voix en 2017 on avait mesuré
à l'époque dans dans nos enquêtes qu'il
y avait tous % de l'électorat de jean
luc mélenchon qui s'étaient reportés sur
la candidature de marine le pen la
j'observe le chiffre 10 9% donc il ya
quand même une progression et je crois
que ça contribue ce qui me semblait être
un point essentiel ou au premier jour de
cette campagne d'entre deux tours qui
avait une menace pour révéler de macron
d'une forme de coalition extrêmement dur
sentiment aux coalitions affective de
anti mac rond et ça ne s'est pas mis en
place comme on aurait pu l'observer
parce que les chiffres montrent que dans
bien sur l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon mais on voit aussi pour les
autres candidats éliminés du premier
tour il y a quand même une majorité de
ses électeurs à gauche qui choisissent
emmanuel macron
mélenchon 36 pour emmanuel macron 9 pour
marine le pen et 45 qui ne se prononce
pas en tout cas où qu'ils ne choisissent
aucun des deux candidats qui ont sa
boutonnière et ce qu'ils vont voter
blanc est-ce qu'ils n'iront pas voter au
final est-ce qu'ils iront finalement
décidé en dernière minute mais en tout
cas ça allait est-ce que c'est vraiment
un électorat clés du coup quand on voit
le chiffre de ces reports de voix est ce
que c'est vraiment michael essayons
alors c'est l'électorat clé c'est pas le
seul électorat ce qui va se passer
ailleurs ce qui se passe même si elle
n'a fait que semer un peu moins de 5%
l'électorat de valérie pécresse malgré
tout ça compte et on voit des chiffres
qui ne sont pas si éloignées que sts à
savoir un peu plus pour emmanuel macron
que l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon
mais on est quand même sur les choses
qu'il est bien un très bon sens c'est
peut-être assez surprenant mais pékin
seulement un électeur sur deux valérie
pécresse va voter pour emmanuel macron
c'est surprenant ça vous ça veut dire
qu'il a déjà siphonner la droite au
premier tour c'est que
l'électorat de valérie pécresse vous
verrez pécresse dans cette campagne est
parti après sa désignation a fait une
percée qui était remarquable dans notre
enquête je parle sous le contrôle de
martial mais était monté jusqu'à 17 17%
je crois elle s'était donc qualifié pour
le second tour avec des écarts de second
tour qui était d'ailleurs relativement
réduits avec emmanuel macron ça c'était
à la fin du mois de décembre bon donc
depuis le mois de janvier il ya eu une
érosion continue
une grosse partie est allée chez
emmanuel macron ça s'est fait
petit à petit une accélération au moment
de la guerre de l'entré deux
la guerre en ukraine et puis il ya eu
une accélération finale lorsque dans la
dernière ligne droite la question de
savoir qui allait finir en tête a fini
par se poser est donc mais il ya eu
aussi un mouvement d'une partie de cet
électorat vers marine le pen et donc
elle a été siphonné si je puis dire
parler par les deux bouts je ne parle
que de la période de janvier à avril
dans la cote précédentes il y avait
aussi d'un extra qui était parti chez
eric zemmour
pour revenir sur ce qui fera cette
généreuse cette élection au second tour
quelle sont les électorats qui vont être
le plus mobilisé mobilisés évidemment le
l'enjeu pour les deux candidats et je
pense avant tout pour aimer macron c'est
d'avoir le plus grand nombre de
participants plus l'abstention sera
forte et plus l'écart des intentions de
vote est amené à se réduire parce que on
sait que la mobilisation de l'électorat
de marine le pen ou vous avez indiqué
qu'il ya un vote par adhésion plus grand
que pour elle-même macron donc il ya un
vrai risque qui pèse sur emmanuel macron
devoir l'abstention se fa se dégrader au
fil des jours là on a les indications
nous laisse entendre qu on ne s'achemine
pas vers un record d'abstention il sera
probablement fait mais pas un record
donc aujourd'hui
voilà donc ces voiliers c'est un chiffre
qui réduit considérablement les risques
de très grandes surprises au soir du
second tour parler de l'image
encore peut-être la confirmation de
certaines choses un con qu'on
pressentait marine le pen gagne la
bataille de la proximité 46% des sondés
considèrent et bien que marine le pen
comprend bien les problèmes des français
contre seulement seulement 25% pour
emmanuel macron en revanche en matière
de crédibilité on en parlait tout à
l'heure emmanuel macron est loin devant
marine le pen pour 64% des sondés
emmanuel macron évidemment lui dire
al'étoffe d'un président marine le pen
elle n'allait tough d'une présidente que
pour seulement 39% des sondés la
crédibilité c'est aussi l'un des enjeux
peut-être de ce débat ce soir pour
marine le pen
assurément assurément pour deux raisons
la première c'est que sur un certain
nombre de dents jeu qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure on voit une différence
exceptionnel à la fois on observe que
d'une certaine manière emmanuel macron
et crédible il est jugé crédible par les
français sur tous les sujets très macro
la guerre en ukraine la question des
finances publiques l'environnement la
gestion de la crise qu vide c'est à dire
c'est cette gestion gère avec des effets
très collectif pour l'ensemble des
français et au delà des frontières
marine le pen c'est tout l'inversé
elle est jugée crédible sur les sujets
sur les thématiques qui ont un effet
immédiat individuel je n'ose pas dire
égoïste mais c'est la question du
pouvoir d'achat bien sûr c'est la
question des retraites c'est la question
également de la délinquance c'est la
question de du terrorisme c'est à dire
tout ce qui peut toucher
individuellement
les français eh bien il considère qu'
aujourd'hui marine le pen est la plus
compétente et vous voyez bien que ça
rejoint cette idée que l'on évoqué tout
à l'heure du pouvoir d'achat ensuite sur
les traits d'image mais je laisserai
gilles qui connaît mieux ses sujets que
moi en parler moi je suis frappé que
on a beaucoup parlé est ce que la guerre
en ukraine elle est modifié complètement
le rapport de force politique ce que
vous avez indiquée est très très
parlants illustratif que une certaine
manière emmanuel macron a pleinement
bénéficié en termes de capital politique
ces recettes cette représentation de son
leadership présidentiel a pleinement
bénéficié de la guerre en ukraine dans
les traits d'image et que à l'opposé
toutes les dimensions de proximité
d'empathie sur des préoccupations corps
et les français et bien aujourd'hui oui
marine le pen s'est imposée et domine
assez nettement et emmanuel macron sur
sur ce terrain là ils ont les qualités
qu'on lui reconnaît une présidentialité
on reconnaît en déplorent un manque de
crédibilité chez marie noëlle et là on
reconnaît la proximité à marine le pen
on dit des manuels macron qu'il est
déconnecté des français alors c'est pas
nouveau non seulement c'est ça ne date
pas de fête qui manyula qu'on soit
président de la république ce il est
rare que le président de la république
soit perçue comme étant très proche des
français s'étaient déjà antérieur et
c'est sans doute ce qui explique le
style de la campagne des manuels macron
de deuxième tour on le voit on le voit
au contact on le voit avec les français
il y avait une forme de dissonances dans
cette campagne de premier tour où il
avait un slogan de campagne qui était
avec vous et il n'était jamais avec avec
les français donc ça je crois qu'il
essaye de deux paliers
de pallier cette ce trait d'image deux
autres petites choses sur sur les sur
les traits d'image la question du
changement on voit que marine le pen
incarne le changement
fortement beaucoup plus fortement qu
emmanuel macron on se souvient que
c'était révolution le thème de son livre
de sa première campagne reste à savoir
pour les français si ce changement va ou
non dans la bonne direction le
changement en soi n'est pas quelque
chose nécessairement de positif et puis
par rapport à toute la stratégie de
banalisation qu a poursuivi marine le
pen depuis des mois et des mois et même
depuis des années on voit que la
question de savoir si elle inquiète ou
pas reste une question qui est
déterminante à moteur du vote il y a
encore 57 % des français qui disent
inquiètes marine le pen et quand on
regarde non pas
ses électeurs ou les électeurs d'eric
zemmour ou ceux de nicolas dupont aignan
disons ceux qui forment le bloc le pen
quand on regarde les autres le bloc non
le pen qui va de nathalie arthaud
jusqu'à valérie pécresse à cette même
question est ce qu'elle vous inquiète on
est à 80% et donc on voit que cette
stratégie de banalisation et ben elle
est largement inachevé ouais inquiète
autoritaire et démagogique aussi sa
célèbre et les qualificatifs qui
reviennent chez marine le pen mais qui
sont aussi assez élevé chez emmanuel
macron se sentent comme chez eux oui oui
c'est vrai alors d'ailleurs sur
exactement sur les trois points que vous
venez de d'évoquer autoritaire ils le
sont autant l'un que l'autre il met
l'humain pour inquiète un peu moins mais
49% s'est élevé et ça et aller en
progressant au fur et à mesure de la
campagne ce qui n'est jamais bon signe
et démagogique on est à peu près dans
les mêmes eaux en revanche on a testé
aussi un certain nombre de deux
qualificatifs de critiques qui sont
adressées à l'un ou à l'autre par
exemple est-ce que le rassemblement
national est un parti
je ne suis plus qu'elle est la
formulation exacte racistes et
xénophobes et ce qu'il met en danger la
république et on voit là aussi que la
banalisation n'est n'est pas encore loin
de l'un achevée qui reste du travail
pour marine le pen et je crois que ça
sera le mois de la fin pour vous
libérer on serait bien resté encore avec
vous mais vous avez évidemment d'autres
obligations merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin et martial on va
évidemment continuer avec vous a parlé
de ce baromètre merci merci justin conn
stein et et si on va maintenant se
pencher sur les critiques dirigées
contre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
oui si emmanuel macron est réélu il y
aura des mouvements sociaux importants
durant tout le quinquennat
79% des sondés 1 c'est un chiffre assez
élevé 1 79% des sondés sont tout à fait
d'accord ou plutôt d'accord avec cette
affirmation
et puis l'image d'un emmanuel macron
président des riches est toujours là on
en parle est un ace qui emmanuel macron
défend avant tout les intègre les
intérêts des catégories privilégiées
72% des sondés sont d'accord avec cette
affirmation
et puis autre opinion testé par les
sondeurs si marine le pen est élue
présidente il y aura des tensions et des
manifestations violentes en france ou
dans certains quartiers 79% des sondés
sont d'accord avec cette affirmation en
résumé il y aura le désordre dans la rue
que ce soit emmanuel macron ou marine le
pen qui gagne ce dimanche et puis
derniers chiffres 64% des sondés
considèrent que si marine le pen est
élue la place de la france dans l'union
européenne sera affaiblie c'est la
stature internationale de marine le pen
qui est ici mise en cause mise en doute
par les sander on a coutume de dire que
les enjeux internationaux ça fait pas
vraiment l'élection est-ce que sur vous
cette affirmation sera vérifié encore ce
dimanche
oui en général vous avez raison les
questions internationales
passionne peu les français au moment
d'une élection présidentielle je ne dis
pas qu'ils ne sont pas passionnés en
général met au monde une élection
présidentielle c'est vraiment les
questions domestiques intérieur qui qui
qui prennent le pas cette fois ci je
trouve intéressant que une questions
internationales majeures
inédite le l'entrée de cette grippe hier
en ukraine à modifier non pas le fait
que les électeurs vont se prononcer pour
emmanuel macron marine le pen allait au
regard de cette guerre mais c'est ce que
cette guerre a produit en termes de
positionnement un petit peu enfouir
foulée pour les uns et les autres et je
trouve que les lecteurs ne va pas se
prononcer dimanche prochain en se disant
est ce que si marine le pen l'emportent
c'est la fin de l'union européenne ou
bien si emmanuel macron l'emportent
c'est la fin de la guerre en ukraine
voyez ce raisonnement ne peut ne peut
pas tenir en revanche je je je trouve
que dans dans les chiffres qui sont
indiqués je suis toujours surpris de
voir l'effet hélas ça confirme ce qu'on
se disait tout à l'heure près de 80 %
que ce soit l'un ou l'autre et lui les
français s'attendent à des mobilisations
c'est un chiffre considérable 80% donc
on avait expliqué comment on peut
l'expliquer en moi je l'expliquais avant
tout par set cette faiblesse du vote par
adhésion c'est à dire que le la manière
dont les français se projettent pour les
cinq prochaines années avec emmanuel
macron ou marine le pen ne produit pas
le je dirais le le bonheur individuel et
collectif que en général une élection
présidentielle est depuis 2002 avec
cette fameuse inversion du calendrier
électoral a produit c'est à dire que la
tente est considérable et on a coutume
de dire je crois que certains des
candidats l'ont clairement exposé une
fois élu je dois mettre très très vite
en place son programme sur les grandes
réformes parce que on sait que cette
fameuse période lune de miel est de plus
en plus courtes et que
c'est à mon sens beaucoup moins que 100
jours ça veut pas dire que
on a bien vu que dans ce quinquennat les
événements mouvementés gilet jaune crise
xvi des guerres en ukraine ont
totalement modifié l'agenda de
l'exécutif est ce chiffre pour moi il
traduit le fait que on est vraiment sur
un vote de rejet c'est à dire que la
représentation que ce fait chaque
français de lendemains qui ne vont pas
forcément chanter
révèle qu' il ya un véritable malaise
par rapport aux choix qu'il doit faire
ou du moins pour aujourd'hui marcel que
la colère ne s'exprime plus en plus dans
les urnes on avait coutume de dire mais
voilà quand on est en colère on va voter
et on exprime sa colère dans les urnes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on se dit mais non
ça ne sert à rien exprimé dans les ions
de toute façon l'exprimera dans la rue
après le vote
oui et non il faut un facteur
déclencheur il faut une mesure
extrêmement symbolique qui va produire
cette mobilisation on l'avait vu pour
pour les retraites un petit peu moins
sur la réforme de la sncf sous le préau
qu'un qui est le quinquennat précédent
mais en revanche non moi je continue à
penser que dans les urnes peuvent
s'exprimer des colères et en général
dans les travaux qu'on a pu mener en
observe que tous les candidats où tous
les partis politiques ne sont pas logés
à la même enseigne face aux colère face
à ce ressentiment est pas la peur
j'insiste vraiment sur la colère
vraiment ce ressorts émotionnels
beaucoup plus puissants et polarisant et
aujourd'hui la candidate marine le pen
est véritablement la candidate qui est
qui qui attire ses colères et ses
colères elles peuvent être social mais
elle peut être aussi sanitaire parce
qu'on a vu que pendant la crise qu vide
on a un fort niveau de colère par
rapport à la manière dont l'exécutif a
géré cette crise donc emmanuel macron
n'est pas le candidat des colleurs et
même le mâcon c'est le candidat de
l'espoir de l' enthousiasme de
l'optimisme et d'eau pour ce second tour
on est sur le terrain le vraiment le
terrain émotionnel des différences
considérables et je ne serais pas
surpris on n'a pas encore les éléments
pour le mesurer mais de ce qu'ont
indiqué tout à l'heure sur le report de
vote on verra dans l'électorat de jean
luc mélenchon qui se reportent sur
emmanuel macron des gens beaucoup moins
en colère que cette partie de
l'électorat qui se reportent sur marine
le pen
civ la rapée 6 72% des français qui
disent qu emmanuel macron des fonds
avant tout les intérêts des catégories
privilégiées est ce que ça veut dire que
cette image de président des riches
c'est un sparadrap pour lui est
difficile dans ces conditions d'attirer
les voix de gauche
disons qu'on a tous les éléments
sociologiques qui montre quand même dans
le dans l'explication et la
compréhension du vote du premier tour
qui emmanuel macron a été le candidat
avant tout des catégories oui
supérieures cadres supérieurs des
retraités qui bénéficient de niveau est
à la fois de pension et de pouvoir
d'achat élevé on l'a vu également sur la
question du patrimoine on voit que ceux
qui disposent du plus de patrimoine en
voté majoritairement pour emmanuel
macron donc ça c'est dans le je dirais
dans l'analyse sociologique après on
peut regarder sur les mesures qui ont
été mises en place je pense que 7 7 7
sparadrap comme vous dites pour le
maquereau de président des riches il est
aussi étroitement lié aux premières
mesures qui ont été mises en place cette
fameuse mesure fiscale de l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière a eu des effets
assez dévastateur dans une partie
notamment d'un électorat qui aurait pu
être conquis par ce ce candidat qui
représentait une forme de libéralisme
culturel sur les questions sociétales
très progressiste et puis sur les
questions économiques peut être moins
dévoilé que ce quinquennat a pu leur
présenter donc oui aujourd'hui mais
c'est cette question des privilèges dont
le on le voit d'ailleurs dans un certain
nombre d'autres d'autres items de notre
enquête c'est vraiment ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure la coalition anti macron
derrière le privilège c'est l'idée
effectivement de ce monarque acquis
finalement on doit couper la tête dedans
dans cette histoire française
révolutionnaire et qui suscite qui
suscite ce rejet et on a rarement vu
même pour l'élection
2017 qui a empêché françois hollande
d'être candidat un candidat très très
faible en terme de popularité mais des
traits d'image qui était peut-être
meilleurs que ceux sur aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron doit combattre cette
idée que non c'est le président de tous
les français et pas de certaines
catégories particulières et ça
effectivement ça sera sans doute l'enjeu
du débat télévisé ce soir juste
peut-être sur cette question de
d'emmanuel marcon candidats d'aidé
privilégiez vous interpréter ce premier
tour et peut-être ce qui va suivre
dimanche comme un vote de classe le
retour d'une certaine manière d'un vote
de classe entre ceux qui vont bien côté
emmanuel macron ceux qui vont moins bien
coté à marine le pen vous voulez c'est
aussi basique schématique que ça
aujourd'hui n'ont en revanche je crois
qu'on a un voeu de classe sociale
beaucoup plus fort que celui observé en
2010 est où il avait eu ce cette partie
de chamboule tout et qui avait conduit
les électorats être un peu désorienté
par rapport au positionnement des
candidats aujourd'hui les candidats ont
des positions connues et effectivement
après le premier tour on peut observer
qu' il y a une forme de partition
sociale qui se révèle et dont on avait
pensé que le changement du de l'espace
politique français avaient battu les
cartes sur cette question du vote de
classe alors le vote de classe bien sûr
il ya une partie de transformation
totale c'est à dire que les électeurs
catégories ouvrières employées ne votent
plus pour les candidats de gauche mais
parce que la gauche c'est aussi au fond
dément transformé moi je vois davantage
un vote de classe sociale qui qui est
liée aux différents chocs qui ont
jalonné ce quinquennat vraiment cette
question à la fois un choc social
extrêmement puissant mouvement des
gilets jaunes et qui continue de
produire ses effets dans le choix de
vote du premier tour et probablement au
deuxième tour et puis je dirais à 1
un choc extrêmement fort choc sanitaires
et qui a révélé que tous les français
n'ont pas été logés à la même enseigne
pour passer à travers ces périodes
extrêmement compliqué et je crois qu'on
n'a pas fini de mesurer ce qu'on produit
ces mesures bien sûr de de protection
par l'exécutif mais il ya tout un
élément moins visibles passer à travers
des périodes de confinement des
restrictions des complications de
déplacement pourrait aller à l'école
pour des enfants etc continuent
aujourd'hui de produire ce ressentiment
et de rejet sur la candidature
d'emmanuel macron des critiques qu'on va
regarder sur celle faite à marine le pen
alors gilles avant de partir à parler du
rassemblement national qui représente un
réel danger pour la république
57% des français le programme économique
de marine le pen est dangereux là aussi
pour 57% des français mais je vais vous
interroger sur deux choses martial 1 64%
des français disent qu'elle n'a pas avec
elle suffisamment personnalités
compétentes pour diriger le pays et 2,50
que je leur trouve que je dise pas de
bêtises 59% des français disent que si
elle arrive au pouvoir nos alliés
traditionnels à l'étranger ceux des
tombes en ou est-ce que ça quand on va
dans l'urne c'est une clé on voit pas
seulement pour le ou la candidate on se
dit mais avec qui elle va gouverner et
avec qui elle va s'allier à l'extérieur
du pays ça c'est cette ça compte dans le
vote oui c'est content parce que les
deux ces deux chiffres révèlent d'une
certaine manière à la fois la question
de la crédibilité qu'on ait évoqué tout
à l'heure est ce que finalement si
marine le pen est élue est ce que les
partenaires européens vont considérer
que la france n'est plus fréquentable
c'est un premier sujet je ne dis pas que
c'est le premier élément que l'électeur
a lorsqu'il rentre dans un bureau de
vote où il rentrera dans un bureau de
vote dimanche prochain mais à force de
le répéter c'est une dimension qui peut
conduire certains électeurs a hésité à
glisser ce bulletin de vote marine le
pen l'autre dimension je la trouve très
intéressante parce qu'elle révèle aussi
ce qu'on évoquait sur la le finalement
le procès pour incompétence qui avait
été
l'arme d'emmanuel mâcon dans le débat
télévisé d'il ya cinq ans cette fois ci
c'est pas tant une compétence sur tous
les thèmes c'est de dire mais marine le
pen n'est pas prête à présider la france
parce que on a vu pendant cette campagne
à centre nombre de départs de sa famille
politique pour rejoindre eric zemmour
est est ce qu'elle à l'ensemble des des
compétences autour d'elle il faut former
bien sûr un gouvernement d'ailleurs le
choix du premier ministre est une une
difficulté sur laquelle marine le pen
n'a pas encore exprimé clairement une
une préférence et cela peut conduire
finalement les français à se dire cette
banalisation comme le disais tout à
l'heure gilles finchelstein elle n'est
pas achevé et non pas un plafond de
verre mais j'irai un mur extrêmement
élevé ce aujourd'hui s'offrent à marine
le pen qui et avec qui avec qui est
démontré qu'elle a toutes les
compétences requises elle même et son
entourage pour s'adresser à toutes ces
thématiques qui sont les préoccupations
des français
non les français sont pessimistes ils
sont pessimistes peu importe l'issue du
scrutin quand on demande ainsi la
situation en france va s'améliorer après
le 24 avril la réponse est non pour une
large majorité de français si marine le
pen passe la situation s'améliorera pour
seulement 27 % des français si c'est
emmanuel macron elle ne s'améliorera que
pour 23% des français
57% considère que la situation se
dégradera si marine le pen l'emportent
48% si c'est emmanuel macron qui gagne
les jours heureux c'est pas pour tout de
suite peut importer suivi le scrutin
c'est ça oui mais le jeu je pense que
personne n'a repris le slogan de fabien
roussel pour cette campagne d'entre deux
tours il y a il ya toutefois un élément
intéressant moi je suis toujours
attentif à faire la distinction ce que
ce qu'on appelle en dorures jargon la
dimension ego tropiques c'est à dire une
amélioration de sa situation personnelle
et une dimension socio tropiques une
amélioration de la société en général
les français restent quand même quel que
soit les électorats davantage portés à
un vote sociaux tropiques considérant
que si la société dans l'ensemble
s'améliore alors ils pourront en tirer
un bénéfice individuel mais cela étant
les chiffres sont extrêmement
inquiétant à défaut d'être pessimiste
inquiétant sur l'impossibilité d'une
élection où tout est concentré
l'attention politique concentrer sur
cette élection et qui ne produirait que
au mieux que 50% des mines a perdu la
foi en la politique c'est ça c'est on en
croit plus que les politiques peuvent
peut-être pas la fois la politique la
foi en la capacité du politique à
transformer des destins individuels
ça c'est clairement aujourd'hui un
élément qu'on voit en france mais aussi
dans le dans d'autres pays et au fond
c'est une question extrêmement
institutionnels c'est à dire que partir
du moment où des partis politiques sont
aujourd'hui dans un dans un état de
fragilité
jamais observée bien oui ça produit des
effets sur le fonctionnement la
démocratie et ça produit des effets sur
la capacité des français à considérer
que demain peut être meilleur c'est un
rapport extrêmement sans filtre entre le
citoyen et le candidat élu président et
cette fameuse question des corps
intermédiaires qui aujourd'hui veulent
en éclats produit ces niveaux
extrêmement élevés de pessimisme merci
beaucoup merci martial foucault dette il
parlait en avant première de cette étude
passionnante pour le cdh hip hop la
fondation jean jaurès et le monde qui
sera à lire dans le monde daté du jour
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
[Musique]